we need to do this in a way that
reflects an appropriate view of the role
of government one that takes a light
touch approach to fast changing
technologies the FCC has just taken
initial steps to regulate Internet
service providers the same way it
regulates telephone companies although
chairman Julius Genachowski has said he
would use any regulatory powers with a
light touch
having the FCC control any aspect of the
Internet is a really bad idea for at
least three reasons the FCC which was
created to regulate scarce spectrum
space was rebuffed by the courts in
earlier attempts to assert control over
cyberspace
despite hypothetical blocking of certain
sites and services by net neutrality
diehards the fact of the matter is that
the internet is working perfectly well
and the reach of broadband continues to
grow exponentially the FCC is far from a
well-functioning agency to begin with
don't forget this is the same crew that
recently brought you in possibly
Byzantine ownership rules for radio and
television stations and hysterical over
reactions to Nipplegate and fleeting
expletives uttered at award shows by
such public enemies as cher Bono and
Nicole Richie
though janakowski stresses he sees no
role for the FCC to regulate online
content all government agencies act like
private businesses they need to grow or
die the FCC has been pushing hard to
extend its reach from broadcast media to
cover cable and satellite offerings for
a long time there's every reason to
believe that once the FCC gets to
control how you get on the internet
it'll start dictating other terms as
well chairman Genachowski has promised
that he'd regulate with a light touch
but even a light touch is a lot harder
than no touch at all for Reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie